in terms of getting people out of their
heads do you have other exercises that
are maybe even physical in nature
because I think a lot of people myself
included like sometimes I have trouble
falling asleep and it just like this
this repetitive thoughts that are in my
brain and I think a lot of people that
you know overthink things are like that
are there exercises to get people out of
that because sometimes you have to
really literally get yourself out of a
physical place and go somewhere else
yes um first you should appreciate the
value of daydreaming daydreaming without
a purpose is an imagining other world
actually does scientifically stimulate
your brain and relax you physical
exercise always important taking a walk
around the building getting your body
moving getting your endorphins moving
some people actually need really heavy
endorphin push to get out of that
hamster brain and into into a meditative
space for a lot of people meditation is
really hard because you let your worried
mind take over so finding a simple
exercise like watch literally saying to
your breath it's yourself in in in
breath out out out breath and and and
allowing just your own voice of in in in
out out out can calm you down
but the other thing is belief when you
believe that you have to get somewhere
or you have to achieve something it's
much harder to get there if you believe
that who you are right now what you're
writing right now is actually destined
to come in the world and you can just
relax and let it come and the thing that
you're going to write next is the
perfect sentence and the next word is
the perfect sentence and even if you're
just writing I don't know what I'm
writing I don't know what I'm writing
I'm waiting for something inspiring to
come to me
I'll just wait and keep typing and then
you start enjoying the feeling of typing
start enjoying the feeling of your
fingers started enjoying a great word
pick a surprising word and I promise you
eventually if you just keep typing that
next idea will come and the next idea
will come and if you don't judge it you
allow the next thing to come there will
be a progression that will take you
forward
you